those hoping that mario party 10 might
finally shake up the series are going to
be a wee bit disappointed you see while
the move to the Wii U has opened up a
few new ways to minigame by the wonder
of the gamepad or a selected group of
amiibo the core game is well exactly the
same as it's always been let's take a
look at the most talked-about addition
here the amiibo on the surface getting
some actual new sounds of amiibos cute
plastic figures of joy there's no bad
thing but there are some limitations the
starters you can only use a selected
group of amiibo with Mario Party 10 for
anything significant anything outside of
that group can only be used in a
read-only capacity to earn Mario points
that can be spent on items in the game
those amiibo that do have full
functionality can be used in the
specific amiibo mode which is largely
the same as the normal Mario Party mode
with a different set dressing here the
smaller board is split into four
sections with whatever amiibo you use
creating the board's theme they're very
lovely they are - at least from a
stylistic standpoint with each themed
board sporting a different set of
power-ups for you to collect and use on
your travel along the circular path
there's a certain amount of strategy
added by having to collect coins and
trade 20 of them in two stars that
appear randomly round the board rather
than just collecting them outright you
can also pick up different tokens along
the way which do things like add more
stars to the board and Amidala coins or
switch a section of the board out for
another themed version from the likes of
peach and Donkey Kong but this is all a
distraction from the fact that the
amiibo mode is essentially just a
smaller version of a full-blown Mario
Party he might be traveling on your
lonesome rather than together in a
vehicle but the end result is the same
well the dice move around the board and
collect as many stars as possible
actually there are some fun minigames to
break up the action which is the biggest
draw of Mario Party 10 and they're part
of a Meebo mode and the more traditional
Mario Party some a more action based
which include platforming challenges and
motion-controlled games others are
slower paced and include memory games
and pattern recognition tests most in
the minigames are a free-for-all but
there are some neat 2v2 challenges to
play through - but what about the
gamepad I hear you cry yes the gamepad
plays a role in the [ __ ] a party mode
for refuse and Bowser amiibo in amiibo
mode one player takes on the role of
Bowser
using the gamepad to play minigames
against the other for players while the
bags of minigames don't exactly sell the
pad as the game changer Nintendo might
have hoped for pretty fun
one of them has he rotating the gamepad
to move fiery bars around while the
other players try and avoid them while
another has you chasing them up a wall
or hammering the triggers it as a party
there are also sections web browser can
attempted to see the other players by
drawing doodles over different paths on
the map or on misspeak rates that may or
may not contain prizes or dangers
weirdly during these moments the games
house YouTube trick the other players
which sort of defeats the objects of the
whole thing but I suppose this way
you're left questioning whether those
helpful doodles are a double bluff or
not so there's a lot of content to play
through in Mario Party 10 but the amiibo
editions and the gamepad bowser games
don't really change the fact that you
played this game many a time before
while there's some fun to be had with
friends we found ourselves getting tired
of the whole thing after just a few
trips around the board
maybe knocking back a few beers along
the way might help but even then Mario
Party is at most only mildly amusing
you